itself and the identity commutes with everything and the situation is similar for the last three so it remains to
check that if we take one of the Z stabilizer generators and one of the X stabilizer generators then they commute
and it's easy enough to go through the nine possible pairings to check that in all of these cases we'll always
have an X and A Z matching up in the same position an even number of times so the two generators will commute just
like xx and ZZ commute it's a minimal generating set and it has a non-trivial code space but
I won't try to argue that in this video and instead I'll leave that for you to think about if you wish the 7 Cubit steam code is similar
to the 9 Cubit Shore code in the sense that it encodes a single Cubit and allows for the correction of an arbitrary error on one cubit but it only
requires seven cubits rather than nine that's not the fewest number of cubits required for an error correcting code to
encode a cubit and correct for an arbitrary error on on a single Cubit here's a stabilizer code that's
usually just called the five Cubit code that also encodes a single Cubit and can correct an arbitrary single Cubit error
and five is the smallest number of cubits for which this is possible here's another example of a
stabilizer code although it isn't really a code so to speak in the sense that the code space is
one-dimensional in particular the code space for this code is the space spend by an ebit or in other words a five plus
spell state so you can't actually encode any cubits using this code but it's still a valid stabilizer code where the code
space happens to be one-dimensional and it's possible to do something similar for a GHz
state so those are some examples of stabilizer codes and we'll see infinitely many more examples in the
next lesson suppose that we're given a stabilizer code a natural question to ask about it
perhaps the very first question that comes to mind is how many cubits does it encode that question has a very simple
answer and to explain it let's be precise about the stabilizer code being considered we have R and Cubit
stabilizer generators P1 through p r that satisfy the three requirements that I mentioned earlier namely that the
stabilizer generators all commute with one another this is a minimal generating set so we wouldn't get the same
stabilizer if we removed one of the generators and there's at at least one nonzero Vector in the code
space as the theorem shown on the screen indicates it must then be that the code space of the stabilizer code has
Dimension 2 ^ nus r or another way of saying that is that we can encode n
minus r cubits using this code So intuitively speaking we have n cubits in our encodings and each
stabilizer generator effectively takes a cubit away in terms of how many cubits we can encode
this theorem isn't too hard to prove and I'll show you a proof in just a moment but first we'll take a look at just a
few examples starting with the ordinary 3-bit repetition code we have three cubits in our
encodings so n is equal to three and there are R equals 2 stabilizer generators and so we can encode one
cubit using this code notice that this is not about which or how many errors can be detected or
corrected that's a different matter this is just a statement about the dimension of the codee
space for another example consider the 5 Cubit code here we have five cubits and four
stabilizer generators so once again the code space has Dimension two which means that we can encode one cubit using this
code and one more example for now for the ebit stabilizer code we have two cubits and two stabilizer generators so
the code space is one-dimensional and as I mentioned mentioned earlier it's the space span by the five plus Bell State
we'll see more examples as we continue on including codes where we can encode more than one cubit but for now let's
see how we can prove the theorem the first thing that we need to observe is that because the stabilizer
generators commute and form a minimal generating set and because every poly operation is its own inverse every
element in the stabilizer can be expressed in a unique way as a product where we raise each stabilizer generator
PK to the power AK where each AK is either Z or one and then we multiply the results
together another way to say this is that we get every element of the stabilizer by multiplying together some subset of
the stabilizer generators and we never get the same stabilizer element from different subsets and one thing that
this implies is that the only way to express the N Cubit identity operation in this way is to take all of the powers to be
zero next let's Define pi K to be the projection onto the plus one igen space of PK for each K from 1 to R and there's
a simple formula for this projection we can simply average PK with the identity on N cubits which effectively leaves the
plus one IG values alone and shifts all the minus one IG values to zero I
values now the code space is defined as the set of all vectors that are simultaneously plus one I vectors of all
of the stabilizer generators given that the stabilizer generators commute the projections must also commute and that
implies that the product of these projections is also a projection and in particular it's the projection onto the
intersection of the subspaces that the individual projections project onto or in other words it's the projection onto
the code space we can expand out this product and what we get is the average over every
element of the stabilizer and finally because the dimension of any Subspace is equal to
the trace of the projection onto that Subspace we find that the dimension of the code space is the average of the traces over the elements of the
stabilizer but with the exception of the ubit identity operation all of the elements of the stabilizer must have
Trace equal to zero because the three non-identity polym matrices all have Trace equal to zero the trace of the N Cubit identity
operation is 2 to the n and so we find that the dimension of the code space is 2 the nus r which proves the
theorem next I'll say just a little bit about how cubits can be encoded using stabilizer codes but to do that we first
need to introduce Clifford operations Clifford operations are unitary operations on any number of
cubits that can be implemented by Quantum circuits with a restricted set of gates namely hadamard Gates S Gates
and controlled knot Gates notice that t gates are not included nor are tofly Gates or fredin
Gates and not only are those Gates not included in this list but in fact it's not possible to implement those Gates